hi there everyone i'm brady i'm the guy
who makes the videos here on 60 symbols
i actually have a few other channels i
don't usually come on here and talk
about them hopefully some of you may
watch them some of you might not but i
do want to talk about something in
particular for 60 symbols viewers and
that's because i know a lot of you like
watching professor phil moriarty here he
is just to remind you he's one of our
more popular physicists
in the head
you haven't seen phil here on 60 symbols
for a little while but i have been
working with him on a couple of videos
for another one of my channels called
numberphile which is all about numbers
and mathematics and things like that
and phil and i have been collaborating
with another youtuber making a heavy
metal song about
actually
about the golden ratio
and it's turned out pretty well so if
you want to go over and have a look at
it on number file i'll have links
everywhere so you can go and have a look
and they'll be under the video go and
check it out it's pretty good fun if
you're not interested well i'm sorry for
wasting just a little bit of your time
but we will be back next week with a
normal 60 symbols video as well